a dominating performance today won this
yeah i think uh
i i missed uh
missed a lot of things today i didn't
play so well but uh he didn't have
asbestos either so
eventually it was pretty
pretty comfortable
uh you still have one day tomorrow
you're now in lead of the tournament on
head to head against brandon how do you
view your chances now tomorrow
uh yeah i didn't think about so much
about that i just gotta
play a good match tomorrow um
yeah last last couple of days have been
uh haven't been great so i gotta raise
my level
when they're not great you're sitting in
a secret lab chair you're in an esports
studio do you do you wish that every
tournament can be played in a situation
like this yeah it's been it's been a
nice experience uh
so
um it's been ups and downs um
obviously so i just hope to uh to end on
a high and
win
any tournament that i play regardless of
the city
and uh mom dialo tomorrow how do you see
that
uh no he hasn't had
he hasn't had his best tournament here
but um on any given day it can be very
dangerous so
very easy thank you bonus thank you